dans l'épisode 5 sur la théorie de la
relativité restreinte je vous avais posé
un défilé et aujourd'hui on va le
résoudre mais avant de le résoudre je
vous invite à aller voir l'épisode où
est le revoir c'est pas obligatoire mais
ça peut être utile
bon vous êtes prêts c'est parti imaginez
prendre une cage dont la largeur et la
taille de sheldon sheldon voler ensuite
vous la gauche vers la droite
dans le référentiel de la cage sheldon
est en mouvement
donc il est contractée dans le sens de
son mouvement et donc plus petit que la
cage mais dans le référentiel de sheldon
c'est la cage qui bouge et est donc
contracté on semble alors devoir
conclure une chose et son inverse à
savoir que l'on peut il ou ne peut pas
emprisonner celle d'un certain mécanique
je vous dirai pas de soucis un truc
question inverse en même temps pourquoi
pas mais on n'est pas en médecine
quantique ou non la quitter à sainté il
nous faut donc résoudre ce paradoxe
peut-on ne peut-on pas enfermer sheldon
en prison dont les commentaires de
l'épisode 5 et ovates rouge fait
remarquer à juste titre que si michele
dunne percute la cage à très grande
vitesse
ben sheldon va d'abord mourir se
retrouve en mille morceaux
mais il accueille aussi va se retrouver
en mille morceaux et du coup à dire que
sheldon est enfermé ou pas dans la
prison ça n'a plus trop de sens du coup
si on veut vraiment mettre et sheldon en
cage en pratique il faut d'arrêter ici
on arrête je donne et maïs retombe dans
le même référentiel que la cache du coup
plus de contraction de distance et du
coup plus paradoxe tout ça c'est
complètement juste vous avez
parfaitement raison mais ça ne fait que
contourner le problème
du coup fait pour reposer la question un
petit peu différemment y aurait-il un
intervalle de temps durant lequel on
peut mettre sheldon en cage hélas la
bonne réponse à nous vient de
monseigneur antipas rasta l'idée c'est
que la réponse à cette question est en
fait relative aux référentiels et elle
n'a pas de raison d'être absolue en fait
la question que l'on se pose revient se
demander si au moment où les pieds de
sheldon rentrer dans la cage la tête de
sheldon est encore dans la cage
autrement dit on est en train de poser
une question sur la simultanéité de deux
événements or on a dit que la
simultanéité c'est est relatif
pour mieux comprendre ce qu'il se passe
on peut représenter un diagramme dit de
mines cause qui l'abscisse représente la
direction gauche droite et l'ordonné
représente le temps qui passe et parce
que l'on a vu que la vitesse de la
lumière joue un rôle central en
relativité
on va convertir l'échelle du temps en
unités de distance en la multipliant par
la vitesse c'est de la lumière
ainsi si l'ordonnait est égal à seppois
t d si elle est dans la même unité que
l'abscisse la trajectoire de la lumière
dans le diagramme de mines peau ce qui
va être à 45 degrés dans ce diagramme ou
pourrait représenter la position de la
lumière à chaque instant du temps mais
on peut aussi représenter toutes les
positions de la lumière à tous les
instants du temps et ça ça veut dire que
chaque photon de lumière va être toute
une droite à 45 degrés de même la cage
et sheldon correspondent à des lignes
qui représentent toutes leurs positions
à travers le temps dans le référentiel
de la cage la cage est la droite
verticale désordonnée alors que sheldon
est une droite plus pentue que celle de
la lumière mais pas verticale en fait
puisque la vitesse de la lumière et la
vitesse maximale tout trajectoire sera
forcément plus pentue que celle de la
ligne
autrement dit les points de l'espace
temps qu'un événement à l'origine peut
influencer sont exactement ceux qui
appartiennent aux cônes formé par les
trajectoires de la lumière
c'est pourquoi on parle de cône de
lumière ou de caunes de causalité si un
événement est dans le cône de causalité
d'un autre alors il peut y avoir un lien
causal entre ces deux événements en
revanche deux événements qui ne sont pas
dans le cône de causalité l'un de
l'autre ne peuvent pas s'influencer
mutuellement
en fait ce que l'on est en train de dire
c'est qu'il existe dans notre espace
temps une vitesse maximale de la
causalité qui se trouve être celle de la
lumière mais c'est cette vitesse
maximale de la causalité qui était
absolue et qui régit la structure de
notre espace plan bon il ya une grosse
erreur dans ce que l'un des rares et
c'est cette erreur qui va nous permettre
de résoudre le paradoxe
l'erreur est supposé dans ce que je veux
dire que celle donnée la cage était des
objets ponctuel mais ce n'est pas le cas
en fait ils prennent de l'espace et du
coup au lieu d'être au point fait par
des droites
ils devraient être représentés par des
espèces de rectangles infinie maintenant
dans le référentiel de la cage parce que
sheldon est en mouvement
la largeur gauche droite de son
rectangle va être plus petit que la
largeur gauche droite de la cage et ça
ça veut dire qu'au moment où le pied de
sheldon rentrer dans la cage sa tête n'a
pas atteint l'autre bout de la cage
qu'en est-il dans le référentiel de
sheldon maintenant pour comprendre ce
qui se passe dans le référentiel de
sheldon
il nous faut tourner l'espace temps de
sorte que la trajectoire de sheldon
devienne la verticale mais on ne peut
pas faire ceci n'importe comment il faut
aussi que les trajectoires de la lumière
reste à 45 degrés
la seule façon de faire ceci impose de
tourner ce qui était la droite des
abscisses dans le référentiel de la cage
dans le sens opposé de la droite
désordonnée
cette transformation est super bizarre
est très inhabituel mais elle fut
parfaitement décrite par le physicien
hendrick lawrence
une décennie avant einstein on l'appelle
donc transformation de laurens même si
lawrence n'a pas su en déduire la
relativité des mesures de distance et de
temps kenji time comprendra ensuite
bref une fois cette transformation à
l'achever on voit que dans le
référentiel de sheldon l'ordre des
événements est inversé sa tête sort de
la cage avant que ses pieds ni autres
d'ailleurs on peut tracer les tranches
d'événements simultanée selon la cage et
l'on voit que ces tranches dû faire des
tranches de simultanéité selon sheldon
voit aussi et surtout sur ces diagrammes
que le fait que les pieds de sheldon
soit rentré ou non à l'inter de la cage
au moment où sa tête percute l'arrière
de la cage n'a en fait que très peu
d'importance même aucune
et ça c'est parce que le premier
événement n'est pas dans le cône de
causalité du second du coup le second ne
peut pas influencer le premier du coup
si sheldon meurt instantanément au
moment du choc
ces puits ne le sont que bien plus tard
un moment où ils seront déjà rentrer
dans la cage et c'est pour ça qu'il n'y
a pas de paradoxe même lorsque sheldon
percute la cage on a vu comment le
diagramme domingos qui permettait de
mieux comprendre la causalité la
contraction des longueurs et la
relativité de la simultanéité et noise
plus qu'une seule chose à voir à savoir
la dilatation des durées et ça pour ça
on va modifier un petit peu l'expérience
de penser que l'on a fait dans l'épisode
5 remplaçant le sabre laser verticale
par un sabre laser horizontale aussi
dans le diagramme de minkowski le sabre
laser et spatialement étendu et il est
donc représentée par un rectangle
les bords du rectangle ce renvoi alors
le rayon de lumière à 45 degrés on peut
maintenant comparer le sabre laser de
léonard da celui de sheldon dans le
référentiel de leonardo à supposer que
sheldon est en mouvement par rapport à
les hold hard on voit alors que malgré
la contraction des longueurs l'éthique
de sheldon sont plus lents que ceux des
léonarde c'est pour ça que la montre de
sheldon semble ralentir pour représenter
cela en indiquant la distance que
sheldon parcours à travers l'espace
temps en 1 tick de sa montre on parle de
temps propre de sheldon car cette
distance et la distance parcourue en une
unité de temps dans le référentiel de
sheldon dans le diagramme de mines pause
qui dans le référentiel de leonardo
on voit que les distances parcourues en
unité de ton propre correspondent à de
plus grandes mesures d'espacé de temps
lorsqu elles correspondent à des
trajectoires proche de celle de la
on
mais encore une fois les concepts de
temps et de distance ne sont que relatif
en fait ce qui est absolue dans cette
histoire c'est la notion de temps propre
le temps propre en fait plus
généralement et le temps maximal qu'il
faut pour aller entre deux événements de
l'espace temps oui je parle bien de
temps maximal car toute autre
trajectoire que la ligne droite permet
d'aller d'un point à un autre en un
temps plus court que la ligne droite
et oui je sais c'est super contre
intuitif donc si on va des vitesses
proches de celle de la lumière
on va pouvoir parcourir de grandes
distances en très peu de temps
en fait même si on zigzague on va
pouvoir parcourir beaucoup de temps
selon les autres en très peu de notre
temps propre de sorte que l'on peut
voyager littéralement vers le futur
et ça c'est la classe
j'espère que vous avez aimé ce dernier
épisode sur la théorie de la relativité
restreinte
le prochain est un petit peu rollier
mais après ce long récit d'un arriver
jusqu'à la théorie de la relativité
générale c'est ça veut dire qu'il va
nous falloir introduire plein d'outils
mathématiques absolument merveilleux
pour avoir parlé de géométrie monnaies
fille diane et tout ça
la prochaine fois la question à laquelle
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez ci est
ce que l'on peut ajouter d'une couleur
là pour ça je vais vous remettre dans le
contexte de mes années de collège ou mon
professeur de maths disait qu'il ne
fallait jamais ajouter des pommes et des
bananes mais que mon professeur d'arts
plastiques me disait d'ajouter
allègrement le bleu et le vert qui a
raison dans cette histoire est ce qu'il
ya une contradiction puisque y ait un
sens mathématique à l'addition du bleu
et du vert ou est ce que c'est juste une
façon de parler qui n'a pas d'équivalent
mathématiques un abus de langage
c'est cela que j'aimerais que vous
agissiez pour la prochaine fois j'espère
que vous avez aimé cet épisode que vous
allez
était de partager le commenter et
j'espère que je vous verrai la prochaine
fois chaque observateur